chantier nocturne travaux sur les routes
ou dans vos gares vous n'y avez pas
échappé cet été
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines fait peau
neuve avec de nombreux chantiers la
circulation allégée et les conditions
météorologiques plus favorables vont
permettre des changements dans de
nombreuses communes on fait le point sur
ce qui change
[Musique]
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux la garde de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce modernise
l'aménagement de la place de la gare
sera effectuée ainsi que sa
végétalisation la garde
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Montigny-le-Bretonneux va pouvoir
poursuivre ses travaux d'accessibilité
notamment pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite je rappelle que c'est un grand
plan d'investissement de plus de 43
millions d'euros qui est porté par la
région de France qui est porté par
l'agglomération et ses autres
partenaires donc la très concrètement on
va avoir sur l'été les derniers travaux
de mise en accessibilité de la gare et
aussi qui permettront de favoriser
l'interconnexion et l'intermodalité sur
le site l'été 2023 lance également la
préparation du terrain qui accueillera
la nouvelle gare de la ligne 18 reliant
Orly à Versailles chantier prévu pour
2030 du côté de la verrière c'est le
parvis nord et le parvisud qui sont
concernés
[Musique]
autre grand chantier le développement du
réseau cyclable plaisir mort pas
Coignières ou encore Manille les hameaux
concernée par ses aménagements à l'île
de loisirs de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
une voie verte au nord de l'île de
loisirs va être créée on va avoir une
passerelle de franchissement de la RN 10
qui sera une parcelle une passerelle
pardon dédiée aux modes actifs au vélo
et à la marche piétonne et donc on va
poursuivre notamment avec le rervé le
fameux plan vélo de la région la
continuité jusqu'à l'île de loisirs ce
qui permettra finalement d'avoir un
itinéraire assez qualitatif et donc qui
va venir traverser cette suite de
loisirs fin des travaux prévus pour
C23
enfin côté route Sky investi 1,4
millions d'euros cette année pour la
rénovation de la voirie à Plaisir
l'avenue saint-apolline et concernée du
côté de trappes et il encourt l'avenue
Diderot et le rond-point de l'épine des
champs se transforme d'autres travaux
sont prévus comme l'enfouissement de
réseau et la rénovation de l'éclairage
public l'aménagement des espaces verts
ou encore des chantiers d'assainissement